hello YouTube I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Rubin report I've got whitney mixter
Brian Noland David Begg now and because
this is youtube and we've got to get to
it quick in the immortal words of my
hero Optimus Prime let's roll
all right so Hillary Clinton she she
came out of sorts people thought she was
been down with the homos for a long time
but she made it official she released
the video with the HRC backing same-sex
marriage but don't take my word for it
let's take a look
LGBT Americans are our colleagues our
teachers our soldiers our friends our
loved ones and they are full and equal
citizens and deserve the rights of
citizenship that includes marriage
that's why I support marriage for
lesbian and gay couples I support it
personally and as a matter of policy and
law embedded in a broader effort to
advance equality and opportunity for
LGBT Americans and all Americans now I'm
not quite sure why Hillary was speaking
so slowly but the message of what she
said we can all get down with I think
Whitney Hillary is down with gays what
do you think I mean and I'm down with
Hillary you know I've always been a huge
Hillary supporter I think it's important
to a support fellow community know in
all seriousness I love Hillary I think
she's the hardest working woman in
politics I think I really do and you
know I kind of I love what she had to
say I really do but I feel like later on
in her in the video she kind of takes
this approach like come on in the
water's fine merit about marriage you
know like she's like yeah trust me if
you want to get married it'd be my guess
so you think perhaps she was she was
leading a little bit of what her
marriage went I know obviously she
supports gay marriage and I love that
she took a stance on it but you know I I
think that I feel like it kind of
translated later on where she was like
yeah it's been really awesome so if you
want to get married too it's really fun
please join onboard Brian do you think
she was a little late to the party on
this it feels like she's been on board
the whole time but are they all late to
the party at some point you know like I
mean her husband was the same thing you
know like he's now like I love gay
people and gay rights and you know and
we're about to strike down absolutely
incredible Bill Clinton just like right
I mean everywhere I go you really go
bill um no but yeah I think they all
kind of do that though where they all
kind of play that card and then when
it's cool like you said the water's fine
you know just dive in and say yeah I
love gay people gay people are great
yeah David does this mean that she is
officially running in 2016 is that the
sign yeah I think it's inevitable but
look it was the biggest node of the day
I mean really it would have been a
surprise if she came out and said I
don't like the gays yeah it was it was
not a surprise I think it's interesting
that Bill did it before she did I mean
he is the Thunder stealer he really is
she's inevitable for 2016 I think
everybody assumes that nothing that she
said was a big surprise today it was
like ya know finally were you guys
surprised that the Republicans didn't
give a rebuttal on the speech they know
better they know better there's not a
Republican in this country who's going
to give a rebuttal to coming out I was
just kidding but you took me seriously I
appreciate that
behind the leather daddies in New York
cried and prayed for years now like it's
no surprise that she finally comes out
and makes us dance yeah for that picture
of her staring at Christina Aguilera's
chest that picture is all her facebook
are you guys David I start with you are
you amazed at how quickly gay rights
have changed I mean they every stat and
figure they show you on gay rights
everything's flipped from ten years ago
I mean 58 percent I think they said this
week now Beck's gay marriage it's
incredible how fast it's progressed I
didn't think it would come so soon in
the mainstream but you know what ask Rob
Portman there is nothing like having a
child who is gay to change your mind
and you know what get it look regardless
of how I may feel about gay rights I'm a
bit understanding of even the biggest
homo hair and I'm willing to give them
the benefit of the doubt but all you
have to do is put in front of them a gay
loved one and they change like this it's
not matter who they are Rob Portman
or a farmer in Florida yeah so speaking
of Rob Portman so for those who don't
know so Rob Portman the senator his son
came out I guess a couple years ago to
him and he just announced he's now the
first Republican senator who's on the
record backing gay marriage do you think
there's a chance that because of these
numbers that the Republicans will
actually have a pro-gay marriage
candidate in 2016 that's like the rumor
right now is there any chance or they're
still no but you know what the movement
that is progressing I think in the
Republican Party is there's so many
Republicans you know people Republicans
that I know that yeah like they're so
over the social issues ruining that
party you know with gay marriage and
religious issues and everything and
there's people who are actually
Republicans with in the purest sense and
they're I think there's gonna be more of
an uprising of those people who are I
think Pro yeah it broke yeah
can we agree though that it would be a
win even if the Republicans were to come
out and say hey listen we don't have a
gay candidate but we're okay with you
guys being gay I mean even that in the
sense might be a win looked at the study
found out today 58% of Americans yeah
are cool with gay marriage first time in
history okay it's gonna happen with the
Republicans I want to see straight
marriage start crumbling divorce rate
you know among straight couples for
years now so I think that is be as
miserable as the straight I guess we can
end this topic with this so now by my
numbers I see top five gay icons I'm
going be Arthur
Betty White rue mcclanahan still Getty
Hillary Hillary as number five do any of
you disagree with that would you like to
throw anyone else I can't be
don't forget the official outfitter of
the Reuben report is bonobos com enter
code TR are 2-0 for 20% off your next
shirt